This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We start today with an account of two communities. One is liberal, the other conservative. I want you to guess which is which. The schools would stress patriotism and respect, and it would be a very rules-based educational system. The houses would be fairly similar. The lawns would be very nicely kept
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们首先来聊聊两个社区的故事。一个是自由派的，另一个是保守派的。我想请你猜猜哪个是哪个。学校会强调爱国主义和尊严，这将是一个非常注重规则的教育系统。房子会相当相似。草坪会打理得非常整洁
and beautifully green and moored. The town would be quiet with lots of churches. That's town one. Here's town two. The schools would be based more on experiential kinds of things rather than then-rote memory. People would prefer older houses with wooden floors rather than wall-to-wall carpeting. They would keep the yard's natural. Lots of bars and community theaters and foreign films, more of those than churches. That was easy, right? Conservatives like order, liberals embrace ambiguity. Now, you may be rolling your eyes or even getting angry at these stereotypes.
而且郁郁葱葱，修剪得十分完美。小镇会很安静，有许多教堂。那是第一个小镇。这是第二个小镇。学校将更多地基于体验式的东西，而不是死记硬背。人们会更喜欢带有木地板的老房子，而不是满铺的地毯。他们会保持庭院的自然状态。有许多酒吧、社区剧院和外国电影，这些比教堂还要多。这很简单，对吧？保守派喜欢秩序，自由派拥抱模糊性。现在，你可能会对这些刻板印象翻白眼，甚至感到生气。
But we all know there's more than a grain of truth to them. So how did these two towns, which our guests today refers to as liberalville and conservaton, get this way? When most of us think about how we came to our political views, we tend to have a straight forward explanation. We use our upbringing and life experiences as the basis for our political beliefs. We imagine that our parents, teachers, and friends shape our views on everything from taxes and the
但我们都知道，这些说法并非空穴来风，多少有些真实性。那么，我们今天的嘉宾称之为“自由村”和“保守镇”的这两个地方，是怎么变成这样的呢？当大多数人思考我们的政治观点是如何形成的时，我们往往会有一个直截了当的解释。我们把成长经历和生活经历作为政治信仰的基础。我们想象着我们的父母、老师和朋友塑造了我们对从税收到
economy to immigration and national security. But what if I told you there is something deeper to those attitudes? Drives that shape the music we listen to, the food we eat, the politicians we elect. This week on Hidden Brain, how the partisan divide in our country might arise not just from our upbringing and lived experiences, but from biology. On a regular basis, right before an election, someone will share an article with me about how science proves that the brains of liberals are stunted. Or a post on Twitter will say, Republicans are less intelligent than Democrats. These claims obscure something far more interesting and far more accurate. There are genuine psychological differences between liberals and conservatives.
经济，再到移民和国家安全的方方面面。但如果我告诉你，这些态度背后还有更深层次的东西呢？那些塑造我们听的音乐、吃的食物、选举的政客的驱动力。本期的Hidden Brain将探讨：我们国家的分裂，可能不仅源于我们的成长和生活经历，还源于生物学。在选举前夕，经常有人跟我分享一篇文章，说科学证明自由派的大脑发育不全。或者推特上会有一条帖子说，共和党人不如民主党人聪明。这些说法掩盖了一些更有趣、更准确的事实。自由派和保守派之间确实存在心理上的差异。
Understanding these differences can give us fresh insight into our political conflicts. John Hibbing is a political scientist at the University of Nebraska-Lincoln. He has spent many years studying the psychological and neurological differences between liberals and conservatives. He is co-author of the book, predisposed, liberals, conservatives, and the biology of political differences. John, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. Pleasure to be with you. When most of us think about how we came to our political views, John, we have a relatively straightforward explanation that has to do with our upbringing and background.
理解这些差异可以让我们对政治冲突有新的见解。约翰·希宾是内布拉斯加大学林肯分校的政治学教授。他花了多年时间研究自由派和保守派在心理和神经方面的差异。他是《天生：自由派、保守派与政治分歧的生物学》一书的合著者。约翰，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能来到这里。约翰，当我们大多数人思考我们的政治观点是如何形成的时，我们有一个相对直接的解释，这与我们的成长经历和背景有关。
How does that theory go? Well, whenever I ask my students where their political views come from, the first thing I say is their parents. And I think we have this sense that those views that our parents have passed along are supplemented by those, you know, from a clergy member or a trusted relative, a close friend. But we sort those through our own view of the world and we come to a very rational understanding of the world and an understanding of what social policies are best to make the world better. social policies are best to make the world better.
那个理论是怎么说的？嗯，每当我问学生他们的政治观点来自哪里时，我首先想到的就是他们的父母。我想我们有一种感觉，父母传下来的这些观点得到了补充，你知道的，来自神职人员、受信赖的亲戚或密友。但我们会通过自己对世界的看法来对这些进行梳理，从而对世界产生一种非常理性的理解，并理解什么样的社会政策才是让世界变得更好的最佳选择。社会政策是让世界变得更好的最佳选择。
So we're going to look in depth at some of the psychological and brain differences that do exist between liberals and conservatives, but I want to start by looking at how differences between partisans are not limited to politics. These differences show up in many domains that have nothing to do with politics. Republican president George H.W. Bush once spoke about an issue that had bothered him for many years. I do not like broccoli, and I haven't liked it since I was a little kid, and my mother made me eat it, and I'm president of the United States, and I'm not going to eat any more broccoli. What do food differences tell us about liberals and conservatives?
因此，我们将深入探讨自由派和保守派之间确实存在的某些心理和大脑差异，但我想首先探讨党派之间的差异是如何不仅限于政治的。这些差异表现在许多与政治毫无关系的领域。共和党总统乔治·H·W·布什曾谈到一个困扰了他多年的问题。我不喜欢西兰花，我从小时候我妈逼我吃开始就不喜欢它，我是美利坚合众国的总统，我再也不吃西兰花了。食物上的差异告诉了我们关于自由派和保守派的什么信息？
Well, we tend to see that there are differences in taste. Conservatives do like meat potatoes more. Liberals are more likely to prefer ethnic food. So you see that, and that we think is part of a deeper pattern. Conservatives are a little bit fond of kind of predictability, of standard kinds of things, and liberals are a little bit more willing to experiment in this come through and food taste in a variety of other things. Here's another example. Research has once went into the living spaces of people,
嗯，我们往往会发现他们的品味存在差异。保守派确实更喜欢肉类和土豆。自由派更有可能偏爱异国风味食品。所以你可以看到这一点，我们认为这是更深层次模式的一部分。保守派有点喜欢可预测性、标准化的东西，而自由派则更愿意在食物口味以及各种其他事情上进行尝试。这里有另一个例子。研究人员曾进入人们的起居空间，
offices, and dorm rooms, and they recorded the items that they saw. What was different about the living and work spaces of liberals and conservatives? Well, conservatives tended to have lots of things like sports, memorabilia, whereas liberals tended to have more experiential things, lots of books, lots of CDs, especially diverse CDs, whereas conservatives were more likely to have things that organized their lives, calendars, clothes baskets. Also the researchers suggested the liberals' rooms were not quite as tidy or as well-lighted as the conservative rooms and offices.
办公室和宿舍，并记录他们看到的物品。自由派和保守派的生活和工作空间有什么不同？嗯，保守派往往有很多体育纪念品之类的东西，而自由派往往有更多体验式的东西，比如大量的书籍、大量的CD，尤其是各种各样的CD，而保守派更有可能拥有能够整理他们生活的东西，比如日历、洗衣篮。研究人员还指出，自由派的房间不如保守派的房间和办公室那么整洁或明亮。
There's even been some research looking at differences in our preferences for different kinds of pets. I understand Jonathan Height and others have explored that Liberals and Conservatives gravitated different kinds of dogs. Different kinds of dogs, it tends to be the case that conservatives prefer purebreds and liberals will go with mixed breed dogs. There are some studies that suggest how you view pets. There isn't that much difference in how many have pets, both liberals and conservatives
甚至还有一些研究探讨了我们对不同种类宠物的偏好差异。据我了解，乔纳森·海特和其他人对此进行过探讨。自由派和保守派倾向于不同种类的狗。不同种类的狗，通常情况是保守派更喜欢纯种狗，而自由派会选择混血狗。有些研究表明了你如何看待宠物。在有多少人养宠物方面没有太大差异，无论是自由派还是保守派
like to have pets at a body equal level, but they might view them somewhat differently. Liberals are a little bit more likely to view them as part of the family rather than, you know, just a pet. So you have those kinds of very interesting things, not just in pet ownership, but kind of in orientation to the pet. The patterns that John and others have identified are more than just curious. These patterns suggest that our model of political differences is wrong in an important way.
都喜欢在同等程度上养宠物，但他们对宠物的看法可能有所不同。自由派稍微更有可能把宠物视为家庭的一部分，而不仅仅是“一只宠物”。所以你有这些非常有趣的事情，不仅体现在宠物饲养上，还体现在对宠物的态度上。约翰和其他人发现的这些模式不仅仅是奇闻异事。这些模式表明，我们关于政治分歧的模型在某个重要方面是错误的。
Liberals and conservatives don't just have different political preferences, they have different temperaments. Conservatives don't just care about lower taxes, they also care about whether poetry rhymes. That's right. Should poetry rhyme, we also ask, are you more comfortable with novels that end with clear resolution, those kinds of things? And you can start to see a pattern already, I think, in our discussion that it is the case that liberals are more
自由派和保守派不仅有不同的政治偏好，他们还有不同的气质。保守派不仅关心减税，他们还关心诗歌是否押韵。没错。诗歌是否应该押韵，我们还问过，你是否更能接受以清晰结局收尾的小说，诸如此类的事情。我想，从我们的讨论中，你已经开始看出一个规律了，那就是自由派更
likely to say, sure, I'm OK with free verse. Whereas conservatives say, no, we really think there should be a pattern. Music should come back to a recognizable melody. Poetry should rhyme, and novels should wrap up There should be a pattern, music should come back to a recognizable melody, poetry should rhyme and novels should wrap up in a way that we are comfortable with. To be clear, the differences John identifies are averages. So you can certainly have a Republican who likes free verse and a Democrat who hates jazz.
倾向于说，当然，我能接受自由诗。而保守派则说，不，我们真的认为应该有规律。音乐应该回归可识别的旋律。诗歌应该押韵，小说应该收尾……应该有规律，音乐应该回归可识别的旋律，诗歌应该押韵，小说应该以让我们感到舒适的方式收尾。需要明确的是，约翰指出的差异是平均值。所以你当然可以遇到一个喜欢自由诗的共和党人，和一个讨厌爵士乐的民主党人。
The point of this research isn't a stereotype liberals and conservatives, but to show that our political choices flow from deeply ingrained psychological differences. Many of us don't realize how our choices as consumers, the cars we buy, the food we eat, the music we listen to, that these choices inadvertently reveal our political preferences. So I'm happy to tell people on Facebook what kind of music I listen to, but I imagine that they wouldn't be able to tell from that whether I was a Democrat or a Republican. I asked John about research that suggests you can tell whether someone's a conservative or a liberal, if you know what kind of movies they watch, what kind of food they eat, what kind of vacations they take.
这项研究的重点不是给自由派和保守派贴上刻板印象的标签，而是表明我们的政治选择源于根深蒂固的心理差异。我们许多人没有意识到，我们作为消费者的选择——我们买的汽车、吃的食物、听的音乐——这些选择无意中暴露了我们的政治偏好。所以我很高兴在脸书上告诉人们我听什么类型的音乐，但我猜他们无法从中看出我是民主党人还是共和党人。我问约翰关于一项研究的说法，该研究表明，只要知道一个人看什么类型的电影、吃什么类型的食物、进行什么类型的度假，你就可以看出他是保守派还是自由派。
It's very reasonable that people would not resonate with that line of argument because to them, it's not like they say, well, you know, in order to be a good conservative, I need to do this or in order to be a good liberal. So you know, they're just being themselves. And I think that's the real message here is that our political beliefs are part and parcel of our entire being. It's not like they're completely separate. And it's just a natural outgrowth of these larger psychological and even physiological tendencies that we've been talking about. The Liberals and conservatives differ when it comes to how they see threats and danger.
人们不赞同这种论点是非常合乎情理的，因为对他们来说，这并不意味着他们会说，“嗯，你知道，为了成为一个好的保守派，我需要这样做”或者“为了成为一个好的自由派……”。所以你知道，他们只是在做自己。我认为这其中的真正含义是，我们的政治信仰是我们整个生命的一部分。它们并不是完全孤立的。这只是我们一直在谈论的这些更大规模的心理甚至是生理倾向的自然延伸。自由派和保守派在看待威胁和危险的方式上有所不同。
Here's Wayne Lapierre, the former head of the National Rifle Association. We know in the world that surrounds us. There are terrorists and there are home invaders, drug cartels, carjacquers, knockout gamers, and rapers and haters and campus killers, airport killers, shopping mall killers. So talk about this difference, John. When liberals hear this, what do they hear? When conservatives hear this, what do they hear? Yeah, it really is a remarkable quote. I remember John Stewart played this once on the daily show. And after the clip, they shan't pan back to Stewart. What the f**k you laugh? And he was hiding behind his desk.
这是全国步枪协会前负责人韦恩·拉皮埃尔。我们知道在我们周围的世界里。有恐怖分子和入室抢劫犯、贩毒集团、劫车犯、重击游戏者、强奸犯、仇恨者以及校园杀手、机场杀手、购物中心杀手。所以谈谈这个差异吧，约翰。当自由派听到这个时，他们听到的是什么？当保守派听到这个时，他们听到的是什么？是的，这确实是一句引人注目的名言。我记得乔恩·斯图尔特曾在每日秀上播放过这个。在播放完这段视频后，他们没有把镜头切回斯图尔特。他说了句“操，你笑什么？”然后他躲到了桌子底下。
So you know, you get the sense that if you listen to this very long, you're scared of everything. The message that I take from this is that you play this to liberals and they say, this guy's nuts. You know, others have told me he's just doing it because he makes millions of dollars from the NRA and he doesn't really believe it. I think he does. These threats are very real to him and we're not going to get anywhere unless people who don't feel that way understand that some people do.
所以你知道，你会有一种感觉，如果你听这个太久，你会对一切都感到害怕。我从中得到的讯息是，你把这个放给自由派听，他们会说，这家伙疯了。你知道，其他人告诉我他这么做只是因为他从NRA赚了数百万美元，他并不是真的相信这一点。我认为他是真的相信。这些威胁对他来说非常真实，除非那些没有这种感觉的人能够理解某些人确实有这种感觉，否则我们什么也解决不了。
And likewise, the Wayne Loppiers of the world need to understand that for some people, they just, you know, they don't see the world as threatening as he does, and they don't think we need to build our society around mitigating those threats. So you know, when a liberal like John Stuart Hy Stuart hides behind the desk, partly what he's doing is he's mocking Wayne LaPierre, right? He's sort of saying, this is ridiculous. It's beyond ridiculous to imagine that all these threats are basically around us. We live in a relatively safe society. And basically what John Stuart is communicating is, you know, what you're saying doesn't make any sense. And what you're saying is, it might not make sense to you, but it makes sense to weigh in the peer. Exactly. You know, one of the favorite things for conservatives to say about
同样地，世上的韦恩·拉皮埃尔们也需要明白，对某些人来说，他们只是……你知道的，他们不像他那样觉得世界充满威胁，他们也不认为我们需要围绕着减轻这些威胁来构建我们的社会。所以你知道，当像乔恩·斯图尔特这样的自由派躲在桌子后面时，他的一部分做法是在嘲笑韦恩·拉皮埃尔，对吧？他有点像是在说，这太荒谬了。想象所有这些威胁基本上就在我们身边，这简直荒谬透顶。我们生活在一个相对安全的社会里。基本上，乔恩·斯图尔特传达的意思是，你知道的，你所说的话没有任何意义。而你所说的是，它对你来说可能没意义，但对韦恩·拉皮埃尔来说是有意义的。完全正确。你知道，保守党人最喜欢对
liberals is that they just don't get it, meaning that, you know, they don't appreciate that it's a dangerous world. And I think that is absolutely true. But it's not that they don't get it because they're being obtuse, or they're not informed. They read about events in the world, and they just don't respond to them in the same way. And likewise, liberals rather need to recognize that, while this may seem silly, and you're right about John Stewart mocking us, how can you live your life, worried, and whatever. But to them, this is very real, and a good citizen is vigilant
自由派说的一句话是，他们根本不明白，意思就是，你知道的，他们没有意识到这是一个危险的世界。我认为这绝对是真的。但这并不是因为他们愚钝或消息不灵通才不明白。他们阅读世界上发生的事件，只是对这些事件的反应不同。同样地，自由派也需要认识到，虽然这看起来很傻，而且你对乔恩·斯图尔特的嘲笑是对的，怎么能整天提心吊胆地过日子呢？但对他们来说，这是非常真实的，一个好公民必须保持警惕，
and is prepared to do battle, to protect himself, his family and society from those threats. What's interesting about both groups here is that there is a very powerful illusion that we have that the rest of the world sees the world the way that we see the world. And if they come to a different conclusion, it must be because they are being deliberately obtuse or somehow deliberately biased, as opposed to the idea that people are actually, they might be seeing the world the same way, but their reactions to the world might actually be very different.
并准备好战斗，以保护自己、家人和社会的这些威胁。这里两组人有趣的地方在于，我们有一种非常强大的错觉，即我们认为世界其余部分看待世界的方式与我们看待世界的方式是一样的。如果他们得出了不同的结论，那一定是因为他们故意装傻或某种程度上故意心怀偏见，而不是因为人们实际上可能在以同样的方式看待世界，但他们对世界的反应实际上可能非常不同。
Yeah, I really, really glad you brought that up. Psychologists talk about false consensus. So it turns out that if your favorite color is blue, you grossly overstate the percent of the population whose favorite color is blue. So I think we need to recognize that. We did a study once as a substance and drostinone, and it turns out that people smell it very differently, just because our olfactory systems are structured differently.
是的，我真的很高兴你提出这一点。心理学家谈到过“虚假共识”。事实证明，如果你最喜欢的颜色是蓝色，你会大大高估人口中认为蓝色是自己最喜欢的颜色的比例。所以我觉得我们需要认识到这一点。我们曾经做过一项关于雄甾酮的研究，结果发现人们对它的气味反应非常不同，这只是因为我们的嗅觉系统结构不同。
Some people smell it very favorably, it smells like kind of cookies or incense. Others smell it unfavorably, it'll smell like sweat or even urine. And some don't smell it at all. And it's a genetically based difference. So we had a bunch of our graduates, students smell this. And I remember one fellow, and he smelled it, and it just smelled awful to him.
有些人觉得它很好闻，闻起来有点像曲奇饼干或香。另一些人觉得很难闻，闻起来像汗水甚至尿液。还有一些人根本闻不到。这是一种基于基因的差异。所以我们让一堆研究生去闻这个。我记得有个家伙，他闻了一下，觉得气味难闻极了。
And it didn't smell awful to many of the other graduates, and he was convinced that this was some kind of psychological trick that we were trying to, you know, get him to say, well, yeah, it doesn't smell bad. It was one of those studies. When, in fact, he just couldn't believe that we were trying to, you know, get him to say, well, yeah, it doesn't smell bad. It was one of those studies, when in fact, he just couldn't believe that people were that different in the way they they smell the substance. And I think the same thing applies to political beliefs and to the way we we experience threats in the world. I remember one of the things that broke the internet was the big controversy about whether people heard the word Loro or heard the word Yanny, but this idea that, you know, the way that we see
这对其他许多研究生来说并不觉得难闻，他确信这某种程度上是一个心理把戏，我们试图……你知道的，让他说，“哦，是的，它闻起来不难闻”。这是那种研究之一。事实上，他简直不敢相信我们居然试图……你知道的，让他说，“哦，是的，它闻起来不难闻”。这是那种研究之一，而事实上，他只是无法相信人们在闻这种物质的方式上会有如此大的差异。我认为同样的道理也适用于政治信仰以及我们体验世界威胁的方式。我记得有一件让互联网崩溃的事情，就是关于人们听到的是“Laurel”还是“Yanny”的大争论，但这种想法是，你知道的，我们看到、
here something must be the way everyone else sees it and there's just this feeling of other disbelief that other people might not see in here the world the same way. Yeah, it's just what we're used to, it makes sense to us. So I do think that's something we need to continue to pound away on that, that we really are wired up quite differently. Let's look at how this plays out when it comes to the subject of immigration. Here is Republican Donald Trump. They're bringing drugs, they're bringing crime, they're rapists, and some are you assume are good people. And here is Democrat Nancy Pelosi.
听到某些东西的方式一定就是其他人看到的方式，并且会有一种难以置信的感觉，觉得其他人可能不会以同样的方式看到和听到这个世界。是的，这只是我们习惯了，对我们来说说得通。所以我确实认为这是我们需要不断强调的一点，那就是我们的确有着截然不同的思维回路。让我们看看当涉及移民问题时，这种情况是如何表现出来的。这是共和党人唐纳德·特朗普。他们带来了毒品，带来了犯罪，他们是强奸犯，而且有些人你认为可能是好人。这是民主党人南希·佩洛西。
We are constantly re-indigrated by immigrants coming to our country. Their commitment and courage and commitment to the American dream, which drew them here in the first place, strengthens the American dream. Now, it's important to stipulate here, John, that it's entirely possible these are politicians. They might, indeed, be saying things that are just politically strategic, but how might differences in threat perception
我们不断地因来到我们国家的移民而重新焕发活力。他们的承诺、勇气以及对最初将他们吸引到这里的美国梦的承诺，增强了美国梦。现在，约翰，这里必须明确一点，完全有可能是因为他们是政客。他们可能确实在说一些纯粹出于政治策略的话，但威胁感知方面的差异可能会如何
shape the way liberals and conservatives in general think about the subject of immigration. Yeah, I really think, you know, immigration, defense, police, law, and order. I think this is really at the core of who we are and at the core of political differences. So, you know, if I am a person like Wayne Lopier who feels these threats and thinks they're all around us, then it seems to me I would want a set of policies put forward by our government that helped to reduce those threats. And how am I going to do this?
塑造自由派和保守派总体上对移民问题的看法呢？是的，我真的认为，你知道的，移民、国防、警察、法律与秩序。我认为这确实是我们核心之所在，也是政治分歧的核心之所在。所以，你知道，如果我是一个像韦恩·拉皮埃尔那样能够感受到这些威胁并认为它们无处不在的人，那么在我看来，我会希望我们的政府提出一套有助于减少这些威胁的政策。我该怎么做呢？
I'm going to do it by allowing people to be well-armed. I'm going to do it by spending a lot on defense. I'm going to empower police. I'm going to have the death penalty. I'm going to not allow immigrants to come here. Or if they do, they're going to be extremely vetted as the president's once said. So, you know, those, I think, not allow immigrants to come here or if they do, they're going to be extremely vetted as the presidents once said.
我要通过允许人们拥有充足的武装来做到这一点。我要通过在国防上投入巨资来做到这一点。我要赋予警察权力。我要实行死刑。我不允许移民来这里。或者如果他们来了，他们将受到极其严格的审查，正如总统曾经说过的那样。所以，你知道，那些……我不允许移民来这里，或者如果他们来了，他们将受到极其严格的审查，正如总统曾经说过的那样。
So those, I think, to a threat-sensitive mindset are steps that they only make sense. They just can't really understand why anybody would be opposed to those kinds of things because this would help us to be a safer place. Now, there are all kinds of confounding factors when it comes to studying how politicians speak in the actual world, political considerations that are difficult to disentangle from psychological and biological traits. But John and others have studied these differences in experimental settings. John once showed liberals and conservatives positive and negative pictures and he found they reacted very differently.
所以在我看来，对于具备威胁敏感性思维的人来说，这些步骤是合乎情理的。他们实在无法理解为什么会有人反对这些事情，因为这有助于我们成为一个更安全的地方。现在，在研究政客们在现实世界中的发言时，存在着各种混杂因素，这些政治考量很难与心理和生物学特征区分开来。但约翰和其他人在实验环境中研究过这些差异。约翰曾向自由派和保守派展示正面和负面的图片，他发现他们的反应截然不同。
A positive picture would be something like a beautiful sunset or somebody enjoying themselves on a ski slope, a happy child. A negative picture would be things like a house that had just been leveled by a hurricane or a guy eating worms or children who are malnourished. We had people hooked up to some physiological devices. The most obvious one is electro-dermal activity or skin conductance, which is a common way of seeing if somebody is just having a reaction, having a physiological arousal to that stimulus. What we found is that people do have arousals when they see these kinds of images, because they have some emotional content. But we tended to find that liberals were more reactive to the positive images and conservatives
正面图片可能是美丽的日落、某人在滑雪场享受乐趣，或者是快乐的孩子。负面图片则可能是刚被飓风夷为平地的房屋、吃虫子的男人或营养不良的儿童。我们让人们连接了一些生理设备。最明显的一个是电皮肤活动或皮肤电导，这是观察某人对该刺激是否有反应、是否有生理唤醒的常用方法。我们发现，人们在看到这些类型的图像时确实会有唤醒，因为它们包含一些情感内容。但我们往往发现，自由派对正面图片的反应更强烈，而保守派
are more reactive to the negative images. I understand that in one brain imaging study that you conducted, volunteers were shown disgusting images, and brain activation from even a single image was actually pretty good at being able to tell who was liberal and who was conservative. That's true. There have been three or four studies that attempt to see if the brain activation patterns of liberals and conservatives is different.
对负面图片的反应更强烈。据我所知，在你进行的一项大脑成像研究中，志愿者被展示了令人作呕的图片，甚至仅凭单张图片的脑部激活情况，就能相当准确地分辨出谁是自由派，谁是保守派。确实如此。已经有三四项研究试图观察自由派和保守派的大脑激活模式是否不同。
And the one that we did goes back to kind of our favorite thing, which to show them these different kinds of pictures. Actually, we had the most luck with pictures of mutilations. And you're right. When we did that, it was very easy to categorize people without knowing anything about them. All we would look at was the brain scan results. And we could be incredibly accurate knowing
我们做的那项研究可以追溯到我们最喜欢的事情，那就是向他们展示这些不同类型的图片。事实上，我们对残缺画面的研究运气最好。你是对的。当我们这样做时，在对他们一无所知的情况下，将人们分类是非常容易的。我们要看的只是脑部扫描结果。我们可以非常准确地知道
whether they're a liberal or conservative just on the basis of that. Liberals brains, when they looked at mutilation images, were much more active in a part of the brain called the S2, somatosensory 2. And this is part of the brain that will be activated if you suffer pain. So if I kick you in the shin, your somatosensory 2 would be active. But it's also active if you see pain in others. And so if you would see a movie of somebody stepping on a rusty nail, it goes right through their foot. Your somatosensory too would be active.
仅凭这一点，他们是自由派还是保守派。自由派的大脑在看到残缺图像时，大脑中一个名为S2（第二体感皮层）的区域会更加活跃。如果你遭受痛苦，大脑的这一部分就会被激活。所以如果我踢你的胫骨，你的第二体感皮层就会活跃起来。但当你看到别人痛苦时，它也会活跃。因此，如果你看到一段别人踩到生锈钉子并直接穿过脚底的视频。你的第二体感皮层就会活跃起来。
And what we saw in these brain scans was that liberals were more likely to have activation in somatosensory too than conservatives. Doesn't mean that conservatives are hard-hearted. It just means that things are happening differently when they see these different images. Now, you could argue that a lot of this research is correlational.
我们在这些脑部扫描中看到的是，自由派比保守派更有可能在第二体感皮层产生激活。这并不意味着保守派铁石心肠。这只是意味着当他们看到这些不同的图像时，事情的发生方式有所不同。现在，你可以争辩说，很多这样的研究都是相关性的。
You could also argue that a lot of the patterns that John and others find are consistent with the power of upbringing in shaping political preferences. Here's how. Let's say I'm raised in a conservative home. I learn to be politically conservative from my parents, but my family also influences all kinds of other things about me that have nothing to do with politics. They shape the kind of food I like to eat, the kind of movies I like to watch, the kind
你也可以争辩说，约翰和其他人发现的许多模式都符合成长经历在塑造政治偏好方面的力量。具体是这样的。假设我在一个保守的家庭中长大。我从父母那里学会了在政治上保持保守，但我的家庭也影响了我的各方面，而这些与政治毫无关系。他们塑造了我喜欢吃的食物类型、我喜欢看的电影类型、我喜欢的
of sports I enjoy. By this line of reasoning, the fact that liberals and conservatives are different on all manner of things isn't about biology. It just shows you how your family environment can affect lots of things about you. There's a really interesting way to separate the effects of biology from the environment. Think about fraternal and identical twins. Identical twins have identical genes. Fraternal twins have similar but not identical genes. If you follow a group of fraternal and identical twins, each twin pair is raised in the same household. Each pair eats
各种体育运动。按照这种逻辑，自由派和保守派在各方面都存在差异，这与生物学无关。它只是向你展示了你的家庭环境如何影响你的方方面面。有一种非常有趣的方法可以将生物学的影响与环境的影响区分开来。想想异卵双胞胎和同卵双胞胎。同卵双胞胎拥有相同的基因。异卵双胞胎拥有相似但不相同的基因。如果你追踪一组异卵双胞胎和同卵双胞胎，每一对双胞胎都在同一个家庭中长大。每一对都吃
the same food, listens to the same conversations, watches the same movies. Now, if you find differences between identical twins as a group and fraternal twins as a group, that suggests that biology, non-environment, is a driver. I asked John what SUT studies reveal about political preferences. We were fortunate to have access to a data set. It was very large, includes thousands and thousands of twin pairs collected by a guy named Lyndon Eves. Oh, long ago, it's fairly data set.
相同的食物，听相同的对话，看相同的电影。现在，如果你发现同卵双胞胎群体和异卵双胞胎群体之间存在差异，那就表明生物学（而非环境）是驱动因素。我问约翰，这类研究揭示了关于政治偏好的什么信息。我们很幸运能够访问一个数据集。它非常庞大，包含了由一个叫林登·埃夫斯的人收集的成千上万对双胞胎的数据。哦，那是很久以前的事了，是一个相当旧的数据集。
But it was a valuable one for us because it included lots of information about their political views. And when we subjected these data to the standard twin design approach, we did indeed find that their political views were quite heritable. Although people oftentimes misread this, our results suggested that maybe 30 or 40 percent of our political views come from genetics. But that bothered a lot of people, and this was quite a controversial study in political science. Many people didn't like that at all.
但对我们来说它很有价值，因为它包含了大量关于他们政治观点的信息。当我们对这些数据应用标准的双胞胎设计方法时，我们确实发现他们的政治观点具有相当高的遗传性。虽然人们经常误解这一点，但我们的结果表明，我们30%或40%的政治观点可能来自于遗传。但这让很多人感到不安，这在政治学中是一项颇具争议的研究。许多人一点也不喜欢这样。
And they tended to over-interpret those results and make it sound like we were saying that everything was genetic. But if it's 34% genetic, that obviously leaves 50, 60, 70% that comes from the environment. So all we're saying is that that genetic component is not zero, but apparently that was enough that some people were upset about that. And so you basically, you're able to tell in some ways that there is a closer link in the political orientation of identical twins that in the political orientation of fraternal twins.
他们往往过度解读这些结果，听起来好像我们在说一切都是由基因决定的。但如果它是34%基因决定的，那显然还剩下50%、60%、70%来自环境。所以我们要说的是，这个基因成分并非零，但显然这已经足够让一些人生气了。所以基本上，在某种程度上你能看出，同卵双胞胎的政治取向之间的联系比异卵双胞胎的政治取向之间的联系更紧密。
And that tells you that there is some element of the biology, some element of genetics that is driving political preferences. Exactly. Now that's well put. And again, it's nice to compare political views with other kinds of things. Height, for example, turns out to be about 80% heritable when you see these, when you subjective the same kind of design, personality traits are about 50-60% political views, 30-40% I would say. One of the big implications of all of this work, besides just being interesting in and itself, is that it helps us, I think, think about the political conflicts we have with
这说明生物学的某些因素、基因的某些因素正在驱动着政治偏好。完全正确。这话说得很好。而且再次强调，将政治观点与其他类型的事情进行比较是很有意思的。例如，当你看到这些、当你应用同一种设计时，身高大约有80%是可遗传的，人格特质大约是50-60%，政治观点我可以说占30-40%。所有这些工作的主要意义之一，除了本身很有趣之外，在于它有助于我们以
fresh insight. And you've made the case that in many ways, the more we're able to see the differences between groups of people as inherent or biological, in some ways the more we're able to see the differences between groups of people as inherent or biological, in some ways it changes the way we think about those differences. Talk to me about that idea, John. Yes, when other traits have been understood to be biological, I'm thinking of something like handiness. We used to think that if you were left-handed, that was just because you got into a lazy habit. My father was left-handed, and the teacher,
全新的视角来思考我们面临的政治冲突。你曾提出这样的观点：在许多情况下，我们越是能够将不同人群之间的差异视为天生的或生物学的，在某种程度上，我们越是能够将人群之间的差异视为天生的或生物学的，它就会在某种程度上改变我们对这些差异的看法。跟我谈谈这个想法吧，约翰。是的，当其他特征被理解为具有生物学基础时——我想到了诸如“惯用手”之类的事情。我们过去认为，如果你是左撇子，那只是因为你养成了一种懒惰的习惯。我父亲是左撇子，而老师——
this was long ago, would beat him on the hand with a ruler whenever he wrote with his left hand, trained him to write with his right hand. So we viewed that as a flaw, something that needed to be driven out. Of course, now we understand that being left-handed is very biological. This is something much deeper than just a lazy habit.
那是很久以前的事了——每当他用左手写字时，就会用直尺打他的手，训练他用右手写字。所以我们认为这是一种缺陷，是需要被根除的东西。当然，现在我们明白，左撇子是非常具有生物学基础的。这比单纯的懒惰习惯要深得多。
Or, of course, the big one today would be sexual orientation. When people realize that sexual orientation is indeed biologically driven and not something that they just have decided to do, then people are much more tolerant of that. So we were wondering if perhaps the same thing might happen with regard to politics. If we realize that our political opponents were not simply being lazy, but rather we're
或者，当然，如今最大的一个例子就是性取向。当人们意识到性取向确实是由生物学驱动的，而不是他们自己决定要去做的事时，人们对它的容忍度就会高得多。所以我们在想，政治方面是否也会发生同样的事情。如果我们意识到我们的政治对手不仅仅是懒惰，而是
oriented to the world in a different fashion, that maybe we would be a little bit more tolerant of them, that this is the only way we're going to get anywhere, if we at least understand where they're coming from, even if we still might deeply disagree with their conclusions. What would you say to critics who would say, you know, the argument that psychological traits and biological differences are beneath our deep political conflicts doesn't make sense, because we didn't always have this deep divide in our country between liberals and conservatives. There was a time when we had many, many more people in the center, the most liberal Republican was often to the left of the more most conservative
以一种不同的方式来面向世界，也许我们会对他们多一点包容，如果我们在理解他们的出发点的前提下——即使我们可能仍然深切地不同意他们的结论——这才是我们能够取得进展的唯一途径。你会对那些批评者说些什么呢？他们会说，“你知道，认为心理特征和生物学差异是我们深层政治冲突根源的这种观点是没有意义的，因为我们国家过去在自由派和保守派之间并没有这么深的裂痕。曾几何时，我们有更多居中派的人，最自由派的共和党人往往在最保守的
Democrat, and you know, there really has been a sorting of the political parties in recent years. What explains this change, especially over the last 20, 30 years? What I would say to that argument is that I believe we have always had this very same division. This very basic difference between people who are fairly sensitive to threats and think we need to be vigilant in those people who are more into experimentation and trying new things. Ralph Waldo Emerson has a great quote, I'm sorry I can't give it to you verbatim,
民主党人的左边，你知道的，近年来政党确实发生了阵营分化。”是什么解释了这种变化，特别是过去20、30年的变化？我对这种论点的回应是，我认为我们一直存在着这种非常相同的分歧。这种最基础的差异存在于那些对威胁相当敏感、认为我们需要保持警惕的人，以及那些更热衷于尝试和体验新事物的人之间。拉尔夫·沃尔多·埃默森有一句名言，很抱歉我不能一字不差地背出来，
but it's basically that the division between those people who are supporters of tradition and those people who are supportive of innovation is very old and has structured the world since time began. John Hibbing is a political scientist at the University of Nebraska-Lincoln. He has spent years studying the psychological and neurological differences between liberals and conservatives. Along with Kevin Smith and John Alfred,
但大意是：传统支持者与创新支持者之间的分歧由来已久，自古以来就构成了世界的结构。约翰·希宾是内布拉斯加大学林肯分校的政治学教授。他花了多年时间研究自由派和保守派在心理和神经方面的差异。他和凯文·史密斯、约翰·阿尔弗雷德一起，
he's the co-author of the book, predisposed, liberals, conservatives, and the biology of political differences. John, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It was a pleasure to be with you. Our partisan divide today can make it feel like our nation is at a breaking point. But my next guest says, disagreement makes democracy robust. Certainly in the United States, conflict has been not every time, but a lot of the time
是《天生：自由派、保守派与政治分歧的生物学》一书的合著者。约翰，谢谢你今天参加Hidden Brain。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能和你在一起。我们今天的党派分歧可能会让人觉得我们的国家正处于崩溃的边缘。但我的下一位嘉宾说，分歧使民主更加强健。当然在美国，冲突并不是每次都发生，但在很多时候
very productive. I speak with historian David Moss after the break. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. There are four words often used to describe America today. It seems like the country is more divided than ever. But the country and the Congress are more divided than ever. At a time when the country is more divided than ever. Americans are more divided than ever. I think this country is more divided than ever.
非常富有成效。稍事休息后，我将与历史学家大卫·莫斯对话。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。有四个词经常用来描述当今的美国。看起来这个国家比以往任何时候都更加分裂。但这个国家和国会比以往任何时候都更加分裂。在一个国家比以往任何时候都更加分裂的时期。美国人比以往任何时候都更加分裂。我认为这个国家比以往任何时候都更加分裂。
Republicans and Democrats now more divided than ever before. Most polls say that Americans are more divided than ever. I think this country is more divided than ever. Republicans and Democrats now more divided than ever before. Most polls say that Americans are more divided than ever. Are we more divided than ever? More divided than ever. Not my president. Not my president. If you feel our nation is at a breaking point, today's show may provide you some solace. Historian David Mass takes the long view.
共和党人和民主党人现在比以往任何时候都更加分裂。大多数民意测验显示美国人比以往任何时候都更加分裂。我认为这个国家比以往任何时候都更加分裂。共和党人和民主党人现在比以往任何时候都更加分裂。大多数民意测验显示美国人比以往任何时候都更加分裂。我们真的比以往任何时候都更加分裂吗？比以往任何时候都更加分裂。这不是我的总统。这不是我的总统。如果你觉得我们的国家正处于崩溃的边缘，今天的节目可能会给你带来一些慰藉。历史学家大卫·莫斯采取了长远的眼光。
In his book, Democracy A Case Study, David argues that intense political conflict to the point where it looks like our democracy is about to fail has been with us since the country was born. In fact he argues such conflict far from being a harbinger of doom is actually a sign of vitality. I think we need to remember American democracy is far from perfect but it is extraordinarily resilient and it is generated tremendous progress. Many people judge political success or failure based on whether their side wins. David uses a different metric. He says in the long term, real success and failure is about the health or sickness of democracy itself.
在他的书《民主：一个案例研究》中，大卫认为，激烈的政治冲突——甚至达到了民主似乎即将失败的程度——自这个国家诞生以来就一直伴随着我们。事实上他认为，这种冲突非但不是厄运的预兆，反而是充满活力的表现。我认为我们需要记住，美洲民主远非完美，但它具有非凡的韧性，并且催生了巨大的进步。许多人根据自己的一方是否获胜来判断政治上的成功或失败。大卫使用了一种不同的衡量标准。他说，从长远来看，真正的成功和失败关乎民主本身的健康或疾病。
Does conflict strengthen our bonds or does it destroy the fabric that holds us together? In today's episode, we'll use American history as a lens to look at how conflict can sometimes bring people together and sometimes tear them apart. I started by asking David the obvious question. At a time when political conflict seems to be pulling the country apart, how can he possibly be optimistic? Certainly in the United States, conflict has been not every time, but a lot of the time very productive. And so I could give you many examples, maybe we could talk about some of them. But really, if you think about, for example, in the economic marketplace, competition,
冲突是增强了我们的纽带，还是摧毁了维系我们在一起的社会结构？在今天的节目中，我们将以美国历史为透镜，看看冲突有时如何将人们凝聚在一起，有时又如何将他们分化。我首先问了大卫一个显而易见的问题。在政治冲突似乎正在将国家撕裂的时候，他怎么可能还保持乐观呢？当然在美国，冲突并不是每次都发生，但在很多时候非常富有成效。所以我可以给你举很多例子，也许我们可以讨论其中的一些。但实际上，如果你想一想，例如在经济市场中，竞争、
conflict, is really what drives innovation, new ideas. And the same thing happens in the political sphere. So you have two parties, you have different interest groups, you have all sorts of different people trying to fight it out. And in the process, you get all sorts of good ideas that are surfaced. And so, conflict, competition in the political marketplace is crucial. David says that what matters is not whether this conflict, but whether that conflict is constructive or destructive
冲突，确实是推动创新和新思想的动力。政治领域也是如此。所以你有两个政党，你有不同的利益集团，你有各种各样的人在努力奋斗。在这个过程中，你会涌现出各种各样的好主意。所以，政治市场中的冲突和竞争是至关重要的。大卫说，重要的不是有没有这种冲突，而是这种冲突对民主来说是建设性的还是破坏性的
to democracy. If you just focus on the conflict, you might not see the real picture. To understand the effects of different kinds of conflict, I asked David to tell me about three moments in American history, where political disagreements were so intense intense it seemed like the country might implode.
。如果你只关注冲突，你可能看不到全貌。为了理解不同类型冲突的影响，我请大卫向我讲述美国历史上的三个时刻，当时政治分歧如此激烈，以至于国家似乎随时可能崩溃。
In one case as we will see, it nearly did. The first moment was just a few years after the founding of the new nation. We think of today as being an unusually bitter moment in politics, but the founding fathers were happy to sling mod 2. Thomas Jefferson's supporters called John Adams, H and her machradidical. Adams called Alexander Hamilton that bastard brat of a Scottish peddler. The Nazi talk was hardly the worst of it. They were deep disagreements about what it meant to be a country. George Washington said he was mortified that political fighting had left the country looking quote, ridiculous and contemptible.
正如我们将看到的，在其中一个案例中，它几乎真的崩溃了。第一个时刻就在新国家建立后不久。我们认为今天是政治上异常痛苦的时刻，但国父们也乐于互相投掷泥巴。托马斯·杰斐逊的支持者称约翰·亚当斯为“一头雌雄同体的恶魔”。亚当斯称亚历山大·汉密尔顿为“苏格兰小贩的那个混蛋杂种”。这种辱骂还算不上最糟糕的。关于成为一个国家意味着什么，存在着深刻的分歧。乔治·华盛顿曾表示，政治争斗让国家看起来“荒谬且可鄙”，这让他感到羞愧。
It did appear to Mani, including Washington, that the country might be falling apart. So if you look at what was going on, this new nation had just declared their independence in 1776. And so, you know, they're jubilant about having won this battle, but it turns out that things sort of turn south fairly quickly. At the time, the new nation was not yet governed by our Constitution, but by another document known as the Articles of Confederation. And they really made the states almost all powerful.
对于马尼以及华盛顿来说，这个国家似乎确实在四分五裂。如果你看看当时的情况，这个新国家刚在1776年宣布独立。所以，你知道的，他们为赢得这场战斗而欢欣鼓舞，但结果证明，情况很快就急转直下。当时，这个新国家尚未由我们的宪法管辖，而是由另一份被称为《邦联条例》的文件管辖。这份文件实际上赋予了各州几乎无所不包的权力。
The states were sovereign. Federal government existed, but it was very weak. There was no president. There was no Supreme Court, just a Congress, and the Congress had very limited power. For example, it could spend, and it could borrow, but it couldn't tax. So the federal government is soon in default. The economy falls into recession.
各州都是主权实体。联邦政府虽然存在，但非常虚弱。没有总统，没有最高法院，只有国会，而且国会的权力极其有限。例如，它可以支出和借款，但无权征税。因此，联邦政府很快就陷入了债务违约。经济也陷入了衰退。
Economists disagree about exactly how severe it was. Some say it was even worse than the Great Depression. Many say it was much less severe, but in any case, people at the time thought it was a pretty bad problem. So there are all these different things going on. And that's why Washington is mortified beyond expression. In fact, he goes on and he said that he's mortified beyond expression, that at the moment of our acknowledged independence, we look ridiculous and contemptible in the eyes of all Europe.
经济学家对当时的衰退究竟有多严重意见不一。有人甚至说它比大萧条还要糟糕。许多人说它没有那么严重，但无论如何，当时的人们认为这是一个相当严重的问题。所以当时发生了各种各样的事情。正因如此，华盛顿感到难以言喻的羞愧。事实上，他接着说，他感到无比羞愧，在我们宣布独立的时刻，我们在整个欧洲眼中显得荒谬而可鄙。
And so what he's saying is, we've found this country and it's falling apart. So as the states are wrangling with one another and we're trying to figure out whether to actually have a workable federal government, it turns out that the states come up with something of a compromise in terms of how to build the institutions of what today we think off as the modern federal government. One of the first debates was how do you build Congress? The small states wanted a Congress that would represent them one vote per state, so a state like Delaware or New Hampshire would want that, but other states, the large states wanted proportional representation, representation according to the
所以他的意思是，我们创立了这个国家，而它正在四分五裂。正当各州争执不下，而我们试图弄清楚是否要建立一个切实可行的联邦政府时，各州在如何构建我们今天所理解的现代联邦政府的机构方面达成了一种妥协。最初的争论之一是如何组建国会？小州希望国会能代表它们，每个州一票，像特拉华州或新罕布什尔州就会这样要求；但其他州，即大州，则希望实行比例代表制，即根据
number of voters. But in any case, as they were trying to figure out how to set up Congress, they came up with an interest in compromise, where they set up the House of Representatives as is going to be organized by a proportional representation. And the Senate is going to be two votes per state. But what's particularly interesting about this is that I think often people think about compromise. And we think, and you hear this all the time today,, we need to compromise we need to meet in the middle meeting in the middle is one form of compromise It occurs sometimes, but I think even more common I think in American history and dealing with the kind of conflict that I see is that you
选民人数进行代表分配。但无论如何，在他们试图弄清楚如何组建国会时，他们达成了一种巧妙的妥协：他们设立了按比例代表制组织的众议院，而参议院则由每个州两票组成。但这里特别有趣的是，我认为人们常常会想到妥协。我们认为，而且你今天随时都能听到这种说法：我们需要妥协，我们需要在中间见面。在中间见面是妥协的一种形式，有时会发生，但我认为在美国历史和处理我所看到的这种冲突时，更常见的情况是，你
Don't meet in the middle you do sort of the best of both So what you see is the small states got what they wanted and the large states got what they wanted. So instead of meeting in the middle or splitting the difference, they did both. So the historical moment that modified Washington also resulted in a model of government that has endured for more than two centuries. The conflict was painful, but productive. but productive. Nearly 100 years later, the new nation was tested again, this time after the election of Abraham Lincoln. Let the consequences be what they may, whether the Potomac is crimson in human gore.
不会在中间妥协，而是结合两者的最佳方案。所以你会发现，小州得到了它们想要的，大州也得到了它们想要的。因此，他们没有在中间妥协或各退一步，而是两者兼顾。因此，让华盛顿感到羞愧的历史时刻，也催生了一种延续了两个多世纪的政府模式。这种冲突虽然痛苦，但富有成效。但富有成效。近100年后，这个新国家再次经受考验，这一次是在亚伯拉罕·林肯当选之后。任凭后果如何，不论波托马克河染红了人类的鲜血，
Pennsylvania Avenue has paved 10 fathoms in depth with mangled bodies. Whether the last vestige of liberty is swept in the face of the American continent, the South will never submit such humiliation and degradation as the inauguration of Abraham Lincoln. An Atlanta newspaper expressed what many were feeling in the country at the time. Southern states were starting to succeed. It was the eve of the civil war. While the civil war brought slavery to an end, David still thinks of this moment as an example of destructive conflict.
宾夕法尼亚大道铺满十寻深的残缺尸体。无论自由的最后残余被扫荡在美国大陆的面对，南方也绝不会屈服于像亚伯拉罕·林肯就职那样奇耻大辱和降格。亚特兰大的一家报纸表达了当时国许多人的心声。南方各州开始脱离联邦。那是内战前夕。虽然内战结束了奴隶制，但大卫仍然认为这一刻是破坏性冲突的一个例子。
That's because the conflict wasn't resolved through the democratic process, but through the bloodiest war in American history. In a sense, the southerners, those who are going to favor a succession, they're more committed to the institution of slavery than to the national democracy. And so when Lincoln is elected, and he poses the expansion of slavery, interestingly, he didn't oppose slavery per se. He wasn't calling for abolition at that point, but he didn't want to see slavery expand. And that was a very controversial issue.
那是因为冲突不是通过民主进程解决的，而是通过美国历史上最血腥的战争解决的。从某种意义上说，南方人，那些赞成脱离联邦的人，他们对奴隶制这个体制的忠诚超过了对国家民主的忠诚。因此，当林肯当选并提出扩张奴隶制时——有趣的是，他并没有反对奴隶制本身。他当时并不是在呼吁废除奴隶制，但他不希望看到奴隶制扩张。这是一个极具争议的问题。
And many southerners who believe that the only way to maintain slavery was for it to continue to expand to maintain political balance between free states and slave states, they couldn't really tolerate the idea that the President of the United States would oppose the expansion of slavery. And so, although he was elected, and I think they recognized he was elected in a sense fair and square, they just couldn't accept him as president. And so what you see is they're putting a policy issue, in this case, an entire worldview and way of life revolving around the evils of slavery, they put that ahead of the democracy.
许多南方人认为，维持奴隶制的唯一途径就是让其继续扩张，以维持自由州和蓄奴州之间的政治平衡。他们实在无法容忍美国总统反对奴隶制扩张的想法。因此，尽管他当选了——我想他们也承认他在某种意义上是通过光明正大的方式当选的——但他们就是无法接受他担任总统。所以你会发现，他们把一个政策问题，在这个案子里，是一个围绕着奴隶制罪恶的整个世界观和生活方式，置于民主之上。
So now the conflict just ascends into ranker and violence. And so I think it's an important lesson of how our differences can be a source of strength, but they can also be an incredible source of weakness. And the question is, do we have something in common that's holding us together? In most of American history, the answer has been yes. At that moment in history, the answer was, unfortunately, absolutely no. I'm wondering if one of the things you are implying when you talk about the difference between productive and destructive conflict is that when people have productive conflict, they're actually willing to say, I believe very strongly that I'm right, but I want to at least concede the possibility that, there is something that I don't know.
于是，冲突升级为激烈的争吵和暴力。因此，我认为这是一个重要的教训，说明我们的分歧既可以成为力量的源泉，也可能成为难以置信的软弱之源。问题在于，我们是否有某种共同的东西把我们凝聚在一起？在大部分美国历史中，答案是肯定的。但在历史上的那个时刻，答案不幸是：绝对没有。我想知道，当你谈论富有成效的冲突与破坏性冲突的区别时，你所暗示的一点是否是，当人们进行富有成效的冲突时，他们其实愿意说：我非常坚信自己是对的，但我至少愿意承认这样一种可能性，即有些事是我不知道的。
And I'm wondering if this is potentially one of the implications of what you're talking about, which is the difference between productive and destructive conflict, is that in productive conflict people say, there's a chance that I could be wrong sometime in the future. I think that's correct, I think that's true, but even if they don't think they could be wrong, there's a sense that if you believe in the democracy so much, there's only so far you're willing to go. And so you know, if you think another analogy would be in a family, right? So a family, we, you know, every family people fight, they quarrel, they disagree about all sorts of things,
我想知道这是否是你所讨论内容的潜在含义之一，即富有成效的冲突与破坏性冲突的区别在于，在富有成效的冲突中，人们会说，我在未来某个时候还是有可能会犯错的。我认为这很对，我认为确实如此，但即使他们不认为自己会犯错，也会有一种感觉：如果你如此笃信民主，你愿意妥协的底线也是有限度的。你知道的，如果你认为另一个类比是一个家庭，对吧？所以一个家庭，我们，你知道的，每个家庭人们都会争吵、争辩，为各种各样的事情意见不合，
but if there's love in the family, the conflict only goes so far. If the love breaks down, then actually the conflict can rip the family apart. conflict only goes so far if the love breaks down, then actually the conflict can rip the family apart. In the 20th century, the bonds of that democracy were tested again. When we come back, the political upheavals of the 1960s and their echoes today stay with us. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We are now in the 1960s. Protest, pick up lines and meetings occur each week all across our land.
但如果家庭里有爱，冲突就只会局限在一定范围内。如果爱破裂了，那么冲突实际上就能把这个家庭撕裂。冲突只会局限在一定范围内，如果爱破裂了，那么冲突实际上就能把这个家庭撕裂。在20世纪，这个民主的纽带再次经受了考验。当我们回来时，20世纪60年代的政治动荡及其至今仍在回响的余波。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们现在来到了20世纪60年代。抗议、标语和集会每周都在我们国家的各地发生。
Martin Luther King Jr. is leading the civil rights struggle. There are deep partisan divisions in the country. It's another moment of crisis where it seems like the nation is coming apart. America has given the Negro people a bad check. A check which has come back, Mark insufficient from. King finds that progress isn't achieved by reaching quickly for consensus. He finds in fact that progress comes from triggering conflict. They are a feeling that if we can get a breakthrough in Birmingham and really break down the world's segregation,
小马丁·路德·金正在领导民权运动。国内存在着深刻的党派分歧。这是又一个危机时刻，国家似乎正在四分五裂。美国给黑人开了一张空头支票。一张因为资金不足而被退回的支票。金发现，通过迅速达成共识是无法取得进展的。事实上，他发现进展来自于引发冲突。他们有一种感觉，如果我们能在伯明翰取得突破，真正打破世界的种族隔离，
it will demonstrate to the whole South, at least the hard-fought South, that it can no longer resist. Here's historian David Moss. I think what was so brilliant about King, but also before him, if you look at the long line from the early 20th century, the NAACP, was trying to think about how do we make change, and what they thought was we're going to embrace democracy, we're going to hug democracy tightly, and we're going to reveal the hypocrisy. We refuse to believe that our insufficient funds and the great folks of opportunity of
它将向整个南方，至少是那个饱经苦难的南方证明，它再也无法抵抗了。这位是历史学家大卫·莫斯。我认为金最 brilhant 的地方在于，而且在他之前，如果你看看从20世纪初以来的漫长历史脉络，全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）一直在思考我们如何才能实现变革，他们的想法是我们将拥抱民主，我们将紧紧拥抱民主，并且我们将揭露这种虚伪。我们拒绝相信资金不足和伟大的机遇……
this nation. So we've come to cash this check, a check that will give us upon demand the riches of freedom and the security of justice. And I think what leaders of the civil rights movement figured out is that hypocrisy is actually can be a plus, not just a minus. So if you can bring it out, if you can expose it, if you can put it in front of people and show that the principles they hold dear are being violated, that in some cases at least forces people to choose. Sometimes they choose wrong, unfortunately, but sometimes they actually side with principles. So this is basically what Martin Luther
这个国家的财富。所以我们来兑现这张支票，一张能按需赋予我们自由财富和正义保障的支票。我认为民权运动的领袖们所弄明白的是，虚伪其实可以是一个加分项，而不仅仅是减分项。因此，如果你能把它揭露出来，如果你能把它暴露在阳光下，如果你把它摆在人们面前，并表明他们珍视的原则正在遭到践踏，这至少在某些时候会迫使人们做出选择。不幸的是，有时他们会选错，但有时他们确实会站在原则一边。所以这基本上就是小马丁·路德
King was trying to do. He wanted to pick some of the most challenging places to protest, Birmingham, Alabama, Selma, knowing that there were some pretty tough people on the other side, some pretty brutal police and sheriffs on the other side who were going to take that opportunity to beat up the protesters, use dogs, water cannons, and so on. So what he realized is that if you could make people in their living rooms see this violence and bring it out into the light of day, then suddenly this hypocrisy, which unfortunately was at the heart of the country at that point, we were talking about equal protection, but we weren't living equal protection. Without television, I don't think you could possibly have done it, but with television, he was able to go
·金想要做的事情。他想挑选一些最具挑战性的抗议地点，比如阿拉巴马州的伯明翰、塞尔玛，因为他知道对方有一些相当强硬的人，对方有一些相当残酷的警察和治安官，他们会抓住这个机会殴打抗议者、使用警犬、水炮等等。所以他意识到，如果你能让坐在客厅里的人们看到这种暴力并将之暴露在阳光下，那么突然之间，这种不幸成为当时国家核心的虚伪——我们一直在谈论平等保护，但我们并没有践行平等保护。如果没有电视，我认为你根本不可能做到这一点，但有了电视，他得以去
March peacefully protest peacefully. The reaction, though, came and it came swiftly from the other side and it put on display this hypocrisy You have been some Birmingham and elsewhere Have so increased the price for equality, the no city, or state. A legislative body can put leeches with northern. So what you see once again is this link between conflict tied to this deep faith in the democracy, even how imperfect, I mean imperfect is an understatement. The Negro still is not free.
和平游行、和平抗议。然而，来自另一方的反应随之而来，并且迅猛无比，它将这种虚伪暴露无遗。你们在伯明翰及其他地方所做的一切，极大地提高了争取平等的代价，以至于没有任何一个城市、州或立法机构能够……所以你再次看到的是这种联系：与对民主的这种深厚信念（尽管它很不完美——我的意思是“不完美”简直是轻描淡写）紧密相连的冲突。黑人依然没有自由。
One hundred years later, the life of the Negro is still sadly crippled by the manacles of segregation and the chains of it. When you think about some of the other leaders at the time, there were certainly people who were advocating some version of what the south was saying in 1861. There were people who were saying, look, the system is so broken, it is so faulty that there is no fixing it. We actually have to break it down. And I think the point that you're making is really well made, which is that King wrapped
一百年过去了，黑人的生活依然可悲地受到种族隔离的手铐和铁链的摧残。当你想到当时的其他一些领袖时，确实有人在鼓吹1861年南方言论的某种版本。当时有人说，看吧，这个体制已经彻底崩溃了，它是如此充满瑕疵，以至于根本无法修复。我们实际上必须把它彻底摧毁。而且我认为你所表达的观点非常深刻，那就是金将
himself in the flag. He wrapped himself in this ideal of the American democracy, and that potentially is what made the conflict productive. Right, so look, there were a lot of things he was concerned about, but he said, let's take these principles and actually try to see if we can all live by them. I think we need to remember American democracy is far from perfect, but it is extraordinarily
自己包裹在国旗之中。他把自己包裹在美国民主的理想之中，这可能正是让冲突变得富有成效的原因。没错，所以你看，有很多事情是他所担心的，但他说，让我们遵循这些原则，并真正尝试看看我们是否都能按照这些原则生活。我认为我们需要记住，美国的民主远非完美，但它极其
resilient and it has generated tremendous progress, economic progress, social progress, political, a lot slower than we'd all like. But, boy, things can go very badly and we all know that, and so the question is, can you continue to make progress? So which of these historical analogies describes the current moment in the United States? Are we on the brink of a new chapter in our democracy? Or on the brink of divorce? I asked David about a number of more recent developments that raised troubling signals
具有韧性，并且它带来了巨大的进步——经济进步、社会进步、政治进步，比我们所有人希望的要慢得多。但是，天哪，事情可能会变得非常糟糕，我们所有人都心知肚明，所以问题是，你还能继续取得进步吗？那么，这些历史类比中，哪一个最能描述美国当前的时刻？我们是正处于我们民主新篇章的边缘？还是处于分道扬镳的边缘？我问大卫关于最近发生的许多事情，这些事情发出了令人不安的信号，
about the health of our democracy. You're still questioning the authenticity of President Barack Obama's birth certificate. Very simple. I have people looking into it. We're introducing articles to impeachment to remove President Trump from office. Given the magnitude of the Constitution crisis, there's no reason for that. This is not based on the real theories of law. This is the congressional equivalent of petulant children throwing a temper tantrum because
关于我们民主的健康状况。你还在质疑贝拉克·奥巴马总统出生证明的真实性吗？很简单。我有人在调查这件事。我们正在提出弹劾条款，以解除特朗普总统的职务。鉴于宪法危机的严重性，根本没有理由这样做。这并不是基于真正的法律理论。这相当于国会版的娇纵儿童在发脾气，因为
their team lost. Are these modern conflicts business as usual? Or has something changed? I think both. I mean, it depends what you want the comparison to be. I think that relative to much of the 20th century, we've been more partisan. We're more partisan today than in a long time. But I have to say, if you look back in the 19th century, there were strong divisions, very powerful divisions.
他们的队伍输了。这些现代冲突是例行公事吗？还是有什么改变了？我认为两者皆有。我的意思是，这取决于你希望进行怎样的比较。我认为，相比20世纪的大部分时间，我们现在更加党派化了。我们今天的党派分歧比很长一段时间以来都要严重。但我必须说，如果你回顾19世纪，当时存在着强烈的裂痕，非常巨大的裂痕。
At one moment, that, of course, led to the Civil War. But in most of the time, those divisions actually did not lead anything like violence. In fact, they often led to very productive conflicts. So I don't think the question, I don't think the right question is, is there too much conflict. Again, I think conflict, especially if it stays in the political realm, is a very good thing. It generates good ideas. The question is,
在某个时刻，这当然导致了内战。但在大多数时候，这些分歧实际上并没有导致任何类似暴力的事件。事实上，它们往往带来了非常富有成效的冲突。所以我不认为这个问题——我不认为正确的问题是：是否存在过多的冲突。再说一次，我认为冲突，特别是如果它保持在政治领域内，是一件非常好的事情。它能产生好的想法。问题是，
what do we have in common? I think that's really, we have to ask ourselves, not how do we suppress conflict, but how do we elevate what we have in common? So, we don't have a common ethnic origin, we don't have a common religion. This country is very different from many others. We have people coming from all over. Back in 1776, the continental Congress, just hours after it adopted the Declaration of Independence, it asked a very powerful heavy wake group of people, John Adams, Thomas Jefferson, and Ben Franklin,
我们有什么共同点？我认为这才是真正的关键，我们必须扪心自问的不是如何压制冲突，而是如何提升我们的共同点。所以，我们没有共同的族裔起源，我们没有共同的宗教。这个国家与许多其他国家截然不同。我们有来自世界各地的人。早在1776年，大陆会议在通过《独立宣言》仅仅几小时后，就委任了一群举足轻重的大人物——约翰·亚当斯、托马斯·杰斐逊和本·富兰克林，
to develop a seal for the United States of America, the great seal, a two-sided emblem. They wanted some marketing materials for this new country. They just formed. And anyway, these three come up with a design, and Congress doesn't like it. They reject it. They come up with another design. But Franklin, in that process, came up with three words that Congress did like.
为美利坚合众国设计一枚国玺，即大国玺，一个双面徽章。他们想为这个刚刚成立的新国家设计一些宣传材料。无论如何，这三人提出了一个设计方案，但国会并不喜欢。他们拒绝了。他们又提出了另一个设计方案。但在那个过程中，富兰克林想出了三个深受国会喜爱的词。
And those three words were Latin words, E. Pluribus Unim. He took those words not from a great Roman thinker, but rather from a magazine he liked, called, Gentleman's magazine. It was a literary magazine, and on the cover, were these words, E. Pluribus Unim, out of many one. And what they were trying to say in the magazine was out of many fragments of literary works, one magazine. What he saw it as out of many states and peoples,
这三个词是拉丁语：E. Pluribus Unum（合众为一）。他借用这些词，不是出自某位伟大的古罗马思想家，而是出自他喜欢的一本名为《绅士杂志》的杂志。那是一本文学杂志，封面上就印着这些词：E. Pluribus Unum，合众为一。这本杂志想要表达的意思是，从众多文学作品的片段中，汇聚成一本杂志。而在他看来，这意味着从许多州和人民中，
one nation, and I think what he understood really very early was that diversity, difference, created great strengths for the country. But what was gonna create that unity, it was gonna be our belief, our common belief in democratic self-governance. So as we look at conflict, I think it's maybe a fool's errand to try to suppress conflict.
凝聚成一个国家。我认为他很早就明白，多元和差异为这个国家创造了巨大的优势。但究竟是什么来创造这种统一呢？这将是我们的信仰，我们对民主自治的共同信仰。因此，当我们看待冲突时，试图去压制冲突可能是一场徒劳的跑腿差事。
The question is, do we have enough in common to hold it together? Political scientists have noticed that both parties are becoming more ideologically consistent. In other words, Republicans are more conservative and Democrats are more liberal than they used to be. I asked David if this kind of polarization might be leading to destructive conflict. Look we don't know, so I want to be careful. History, I'm a historian, I look backwards, I'm not so good at predicting the future and I think none of us are.
问题在于，我们是否有足够的共同点把这个国家凝聚在一起？政治学者们注意到，两党在意识形态上正变得越来越一致。换句话说，共和党人比过去更保守，民主党人也比过去更自由。我问大卫，这种极化是否会导致破坏性的冲突。听着，我们不知道，所以我想要谨慎一点。历史——我是一名历史学家，我回顾过去，我并不擅长预测未来，我想我们谁也不擅长。
So we don't know if this type of conflict is itself dangerous. I guess I'm not convinced that it is. I think a much bigger concern and if you look at, for example, Gallup asked this question on a regular basis, if you asked, do you have confidence in your fellow Americans to make decisions as part of our democracy? Actually, that number has been falling quite dramatically. And the number who say that they have little or no confidence in their fellow Americans has increased sharply from about 15% in the early 1970s
所以我们不知道这种类型的冲突本身是否危险。我猜我并不确信它是危险的。我认为一个大得多、更令人担忧的问题是——如果你看看，例如盖洛普经常提出的这个问题：如果你问，你是否有信心让同胞们作为我们民主的一部分来做出决定？事实上，这个数字一直在急剧下降。而那些表示对同胞几乎没有信心或完全没有信心的人数已经急剧增加，从20世纪70年代初的约15%
to about 43% today. Those are big numbers. I have to say I worry much more about those numbers than ideological conformity and so on. I think the question is, do you have some faith in those around you, even if you disagree with them sharply? Do you believe in the system? Are you willing, when you lose, to accept it? And are you going to be treated with some degree of respect you believe in the system? Are you willing when you lose to accept it?
上升到今天的约43%。这是一个很大的数字。我必须说，比起意识形态的一致性等等，我更担忧这些数字。我认为问题在于：你对身边的人是否还有一些信任，即使你与他们存在严重的分歧？你是否信仰这个系统？当你输了的时候，你是否愿意接受它？当你输的时候，你是否相信自己会受到一定程度的尊重？你是否信仰这个系统？当你输了的时候，你是否愿意接受它？
And are you going to be treated with some degree of respect when you lose as well? You know, as we think about winning and losing, we have to lose with grace and we have to win with grace as well. And maybe we just have to be careful not to let the winning and losing become a value of its own. I'm wondering as you're thinking about the long sweep of history, it's clear there have
并且当你输了的时候，你也将会受到某种程度的尊重吗？你知道的，当我们考虑输赢时，我们必须优雅地接受失败，我们也必须优雅地赢得胜利。也许我们只是必须小心，不要让输赢本身变成一种价值。我在想，当你思考漫长的历史长河时，很明显有过
been many, many, many examples where things look like they're falling apart and they haven't. And the case you make as a result is that the country is resilient. But I'm wondering if this belief in our resilience can hide the fact that sometimes actually we might be at risk. In other words, it's only in hindsight that you know that a certain thing turned out well or badly in the moment, how do you know which way it's gonna go? Right, so I think you need to look at, is the culture of democracy strong enough to hold us together?
许许多多的例子，当时的情况看起来似乎正在四分五裂，但它们最终并没有。因此，你得出的结论是，这个国家具有韧性。但我在想，这种对我们韧性的信仰是否会掩盖这样一个事实：有时实际上我们可能正处于危险之中。换句话说，只有事后诸葛亮，你才知道某件事结果是好是坏；在当时，你如何知道它会走向何方？没错，所以我认为你需要审视：民主文化是否强大到足以将我们凝聚在一起？
That's the question I keep asking. How do you know? You need to look at your politicians, look at the ones on your side who agree with you. And do you see them ever putting democracy in second place? And how often do they do it? So I'll leave it to listeners to make that decision. My guess is you can find some examples of that
这就是我一直在问的问题。你怎么知道？你需要审视你的政治家，审视那些站在你这一边、与你意见一致的人。你是否曾看到他们将民主置于第二位？他们这样做的频率有多高？所以我会把这个决定留给听众去做出。我的猜测是，你可以找到一些这样的例子，
and you can find examples in history. The more severe that becomes, the more dangerous it becomes. It's good, I think, in a democracy to be hypercontracts. That is, to think that our system might be sick. Because when you think it might be sick, you start to take some action. One of the other factors you identify that's different about partisanship today from partisanship in the past is that you say partisanship in the past was more exuberant. What do you mean by exuberant partisanship and how could we bring that back?
你也能在历史中找到这样的例子。这种情况变得越严重，它就越危险。我认为，在一个民主国家中保持高度警惕是一件好事。也就是说，认为我们的系统可能生病了。因为当你认为它可能生病时，你就会开始采取一些行动。你指出的另一个关于今天的党派之争与过去的党派之争的不同之处在于，你说过去的党派之争更加热情洋溢。你所说的热情洋溢的党派之争是什么意思？我们又该如何将其找回？
So as you say, I think if you go back into the 19th century, partisanship was extremely, extremely strong. But there was a life in it, an excitement, and that came out, for example, beautifully on Election Day. Election Day was a celebration, it was a party, it was completely different from Election Day today. What do I mean by that? Well, back then, actually, voting was public. You would go and cast a ballot, your ballot usually had a color. It might be pink, it might be blue, and it would reflect what party you were voting for. Everyone could see when you put the ballot in. And there were a lot of people around you. In fact, usually at your voting place, there was a celebration going on.
正如你所说，我认为如果你回到19世纪，党派之争极其、极其强烈。但其中有一种生命力、一种兴奋感，而这一点，例如在选举日得到了精彩的体现。选举日曾是一个庆典，是一个派对，它与今天的选举日完全不同。我这话是什么意思？嗯，在过去，实际上投票是公开的。你会去投选票，你的选票通常是有颜色的。可能是粉红色的，可能是蓝色的，它反映了你投的是哪个党派。每个人都能看到你把选票投进去。而且你身边有很多很多人。事实上，通常在你的投票点，都会有一场庆祝活动正在进行。
There was a lot of debating. There was a lot of drinking. There was a lot of fighting. There was a lot going on. Overall, the voting rates were up at 75%, 80%. So very high voting rates much higher than we have today. So there was this celebratory atmosphere that was going on at every election day. And part of that was something we wouldn't want to repeat.
有很多辩论。有很多饮酒。有很多争吵。有很多事情在发生。总体而言，投票率高达75%、80%。所以投票率非常高，远高于我们今天的投票率。因此，每个选举日都有这种节日般的氛围。其中有一部分是我们不想重复的。
So you know why were ballots so public? Why was voting so public? Well part of it was political machines wanted to be able to pay people off to vote for their party. And you couldn't really pay people off if you couldn't see how they were going to vote. So if you're going to pay them a dollar to vote this way or that, you had to make sure you knew how they're actually going to vote. So you had to have someone at the polling place watch them put the vote in. So there was a downside. There was a corruption associated with this old system.
所以你知道，为什么选票会如此公开？为什么投票会如此公开？嗯，部分原因在于政治机器希望能够花钱收买人们为他们的党派投票。如果你看不到人们如何投票，你就无法真正花钱收买他们。所以如果你要付给他们一美元让他们这样或那样投票，你必须确保你知道他们实际上是如何投票的。因此，你必须在投票站安排一个人看着他们把票投进去。所以这有一个阴暗面。这种旧系统伴随着腐败。
But unfortunately when we fixed that, we ended up taking the life out of voting. And now most people go, they vote, they vote in a private booth and they make their decision, they walk out, they may be by a brownie to bake sale or something. And that's about it. But there is a question, could we have a little bit more of that celebratory atmosphere? Could election day be a holiday? Could it be more of a celebration? And what you'd see is a lot more people engaged in the democracy. So we got a cleaner electoral system. I wouldn't want to give that up, but boy, we lost something in the process.
但不幸的是，当我们修复了这个问题时，我们也抽干了投票的生命力。现在大多数人去投票，他们在私密的投票间里投票，做出决定，然后走出来，也许顺便买个布朗尼蛋糕或做点别的。事情差不多就结束了。但这里有个问题：我们能否重新拥有那种稍微多一点的节日气氛？选举日能成为一个法定假日吗？它能更像一个庆典吗？你会看到更多的人参与到民主中来。所以我们得到了一个更干净的选举系统。我不想放弃这一点，但是天哪，我们在过程中确实失去了某些东西。
David Moss is the author of Democracy, a case study. He's a historian at Harvard University. This week's episode was produced by Thomas Liu, Maggie Penman and Parth Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle, Artimeklil's Reina Cohen, Jenishmet, Laura Quarell, and Angus Chen. A run sun hero this week is listener Betsy Ballon. Every month, Betsy loads her podcast feed with hidden brain and makes a 14-hour drive to visit her son in a Texas prison.
大卫·莫斯是《民主：一个案例研究》一书的作者。他是哈佛大学的历史学家。本周的节目由托马斯·刘、玛吉·彭曼和帕思·沙阿制作。由塔拉·博伊尔、阿尔蒂梅克利尔的雷娜·科恩、杰尼斯梅特、劳拉·夸雷尔和安格斯·陈剪辑。本周的无名英雄是听众贝丝·巴隆。每个月，贝丝都会在播客动态里下载《隐藏的大脑》，然后驱车14个小时去德克萨斯州的一所监狱探望儿子。
During their visit, Betsy tells him about the story she's listened to on the way. In an email, she wrote, A Texas prison is not a place of rehabilitation, but a place where men and women are demeaned, dehumanized, diminished to a number. But for those few hours during a visit, my son is mad. Son, husband, daddy, brother, friend. Through your podcast, she says,
在探视期间，贝丝会把路上听到的故事讲给他听。她在电子邮件中写道：德克萨斯州的监狱不是一个改造人的地方，而是一个男人和女人被贬低、被剥夺人性、被缩减为一个数字的地方。但在探视的那短短几个小时里，我的儿子是疯狂的。儿子、丈夫、爸爸、哥哥、朋友。通过你们的播客，她说，
you have joined us on this journey. Your stories have become a part of our story. Thanks, Betsy. Notes like yours are a source of inspiration to all of us at Hidden Brain. Before we go today, we're looking for your help with the story we're working on. When you were a kid, maybe you felt like Mr. Rogers or Big Bird was speaking just to
你们加入了我们的这段旅程。你们的故事已经成了我们故事的一部分。谢谢你，贝丝。像你这样的来信是我们《隐藏的大脑》所有人的灵感源泉。在我们今天结束之前，我们需要你帮忙完成一个我们正在制作的故事。当你还是个孩子的时候，也许你觉得罗杰斯先生或大鸟在对你一个人说话。
you. As an adult, maybe it seems that Beyonce is the only person who really understands you. If so, you've been in a parasocial relationship, a one-sided social interaction, that can sometimes feel as real as any friendship. We want to talk about these relationships in an upcoming episode. Has your love for celebrity ever given you a sense of identity and purpose? Has a character in a TV show or movie influenced your career path, even the course of your life? Has your connection to a famous person
作为一个成年人，也许你觉得碧昂丝是唯一真正理解你的人。如果是这样，你就陷入了一种准社会关系，这是一种单方面的社交互动，有时感觉就像任何真正的友谊一样真实。我们想在接下来的节目中谈论这些关系。你对名人的喜爱是否曾给你带来一种身份认同感和目标感？电视节目或电影中的角色是否曾影响你的职业道路，甚至是你的人生轨迹？你与名人的联系是否
ever caused you pain. If you're willing to share your story with us, record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. Use the subject line, secret friends. That email again is hiddenbrain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
曾给你带来痛苦。如果你愿意与我们分享你的故事，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：hiddenbrain@npr.org。使用主题行：秘密朋友。再次重复这个邮箱地址是 hiddenbrain@npr.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。您这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。